hey everybody it's mikee from orderflows
and hope everyone's doing well I'm doing
good Daniel glad you can make it out for
uh for today's presentation you know
we'll get started in about uh a few
seconds here I'm just making sure
everything is working fine uh looks like
sound is working you know I had a little
popup literally it always happens you
know soon about to go live um you know
some little popup things comes up but it
looks like everything is working great
so uh we'll get started here so again
you know I'm not going to try and make
this some big long drawn out sales pitch
actually what really what I want to do
is I just want to show you guys the new
uh orderflows Trader 7 this is uh our
last upgrade was orderflows version six
which happened in I think October of
2022 so it's about a year and a half um
since since then and we've added uh 13
tools to really improve the trading 13
tools and we've made some adjustments
two adjustments as well um to how the
footprint looks and well one is how the
footprint looks and the other is uh an
improvement in my opinion to the
existing tool set that's already there
okay Rick um yeah you know I I saw your
your email um I just been so busy
getting ready for this launch of of
seven I haven't had a chance to reply
but uh I I'll get to that uh quazy asks
is this available on go charting also
not yet um it's probably going to come
later you know goting is the uh the the
platform um you know the uh what do you
call it the webbased platform they've
got a new um what do you want to call it
uh some new connections coming out but
they're
not quite there where I need it to be um
they're adding cbot NX and comx
but um we'll get uh we'll get to that uh
probably down the line once all the
other exchanges are there um all right
so let's uh jump in here so again you
know you guys all know who I am I don't
need to introduce myself uh that much
further but you know just before we jump
in just a brief disclaimer again you
know this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
you know we are all adults you know
we're all Traders we know money is
involved and we know the risks
associated with uh trading um so just uh
you know don't risk money you can't
afford to lose and again you know we all
know who I am uh but for those that
don't um that are new here you know my
name is Michael BOS and I've got over 25
years of professional trading experience
you know I started in the 90s with Dean
witer Reynolds on the CME floor
eventually left the floor when
electronic trading was starting um spent
two years on their Globex trading desk
that was like their night desk you know
where we could trade electronically
after that I left to go to EDF man in
Chicago on their macro
Futures Trading desk I spent two years
there made some great friends there that
I still talk to to this day and uh after
that I joined Commerce Bank in Chicago
as a licensed urex Trader you know I was
trading buns bobbles
shats Dax uh Euro stocks against the US
stuff at
night um then I joined Cargill I ended
up being a head of Futures Trading or
not the head of future training but
rather the I ran the training desk at
Carill in Singapore I worked in Chicago
then the exchange in Singapore was
closing down they sent me out to
Singapore to set up a trading desk and I
did that for a year before that division
was sold off to refco which
spectacularly went bankrupt uh six weeks
later um then uh eventually I joined JP
Morgan where I spent nine years there
vice president of Futures Trading in
Singapore 2015 I started the orderflows
trader software company and the reason I
started it is because you know I was
trading for myself after I left JP
Morgan in 2013 13 and the software that
was out there was decent is just
basically a footprint chart you know and
analyzing order flow you know there's
things you go on to look for over and
over and over and so I met with a
programmer and I said hey can you put
these tools on there I started with four
tools right the ratios um basically uh
what we call imbalance
reversals uh Delta
Divergence and uh zero prints or sorry
five and exhaustion prints those
technically five but I I really consider
it four um those were the four or five
rather um tools that came out in
2015 okay and now it's 2024 it's almost
10 years later we got about 32 tools
that help Traders analyze the order flow
but uh before I I get into it you know
if you're a ninja Trader you got to be
on the most recent version of ninja Trad
TR which is
8.1.2 point1 okay and you can find that
by going to the ninja Trader control
panel you know right here and you're
going to click on help go to about
you're going to get this thing that pops
up and it's going to say what it is if
you're not on that version download it
okay because
the upgrade of orderflows Trader 7 now
if you're a first time user to order
flow uh Trader you're fine as long as
you have the new version but if you're
an existing Trader if using six or or
even a lower version like five I don't
think many people are using five but I I
think there are just a handful
um you're going to run into a problem
ninja Trader is going to hang when you
try to load orderflows Trader 7 because
when you open up the new version right
and and you have it on an old chart
template well it's trying to do work on
the order
flow so it's like calling up functions
that's not on the template that you
already have saved okay and that's just
going to cause you a huge headache so
you really got to start with a fresh
chart and it's not that difficult it
sounds more um more work than it than it
really is but it but it's really not and
I'm just going to show you really quick
okay so here right I got ninja Trader
right here right and all you got to do
is go to
chart right click on chart okay open up
a new chart simple
um do e- minis make sure tick replay is
enabled okay and this is just this
plain ninja Trader black screen right
the black chart I don't understand that
right I mean we we read books I mean you
know or Kindle stuff um it's a white
background with black text so trying to
analyze you know I've never understood
why they make their default like this
they should at least give Traders a
choice but the good news is it's very
easy to change okay so there's a couple
things I'll change first is I'm going to
go into the candlesticks candle body
candle
wick I do like to have that black
because I'm going to be using a white
background so that's the first thing
okay simple takes two seconds to do on a
black chart you can't see it but when
you change it to White go to properties
so you can there two ways to do it you
can click on the screen pull up this go
down to Properties or go to uh contrl T
okay and and I like the font size to be
a little bigger rather than eight I
don't like to have to squint at my chart
so I make it about 16 I will add show
date range so I know you know the date
that I'm the day I'm looking at
sometimes we're looking at stuff in the
past and we're like hey when did that
happen um and then you're going to
change the color of the background chart
background under colors right in here
very easy takes you know to do this you
know if if you've done it before it's
very quick I like to make I'm sorry the
Crosshair is uh black not transparent so
chart background is going to be white
white everything else should be either
black or transparent and I'll tell you
text right you're not going to use a
gray text on a white background you it's
going to be difficult to read so you
make the text black the axis which is
the lines on the side of your chart make
that black okay black crosshairs
obviously you're going to want those to
be black as well um I like it a little
stronger so one for the width I just
changed it to grid lines some people
like um you know those are those lines
on your chart if you want them fine
don't need to change it but I just like
to keep it transparent um in the sense
that it doesn't show up on the chart
because it's transparent and panel
splitter you can change that if you want
to or not if you run stuff on the bottom
of your charts under the
footprint
then you know it'll just have a black
line so that's it okay so you got your
white chart all you got to do is and
just add it to a
chart
now one quick thing here so I'm going to
add it here real quick again if you're a
first-time
user you don't you will need to enter
your license token you need to enter it
here just once then click apply um so
that the footprint will go if you're an
existing user you don't need to re-enter
your license token it'll work with your
existing license token okay and give it
a second now one quick thing though when
I say open up a new chart okay um what
you have to
do is you got to go into your documents
folder okay your documents folder go to
Ninja Trader 8 go to uh where's it under
templates okay go to
chart okay you see mine is empty I've
cleared this out already um what you
could do you know if you have stuff
saved like existing charts you could
just copy them and put them in another
folder just create another folder in
your documents you know um you can see I
got ninja Trader 8 back backup okay well
one's empty right now but if I were to
copy it and save it I would save it in
here just you know I just create a
folder called templates put it in there
because again if you have anything in
your chart
templates right and you're loading up
ninja Trader
7 and you're already running other
charts here on your screen again it's
going to cuz now that you've overwritten
ninja order flows Trader 6 it's going to
cause a little bit of an issue because
it's trying to read stuff you know the
new
tools is trying to
analyze the order flow but the template
is an old template okay so you're going
to need to just clear out your templates
you can just copy and paste them into
another one as a backup if you want I
just deleted mine because I I can start
from scratch it's very easy see very
quick to set up a chart right now the
defaults just really quick the defaults
in here are set up
for an e- mini one minute chart which is
fine for most markets honestly you know
crude oil gold um the currencies you
could start here with this chart um
settings okay and the only things that
are enabled not everything is enabled um
we've got the Delta Divergence is
enabled we have um The prominent pointed
controls orderflow
ratios and see here and the value areas
okay those are the only things that are
enabled right now so it's a little
slightly different than the um orderflow
Trader six right there's a few more
things enabled but uh you know we sort
of narrowed it down to these new um the
this handful of tools all right because
again you don't want to overwhelm people
when they're getting started now there
the new indicators okay let's talk about
that real quick so there's accumulation
distribution open point of control
aligned point of
controls orderflow gaps the imbalance
reload volume decline POC wave Delta
tail resting liquidity vertical
liquidity Delta breakout retail suck
price action Divergence okay and there
are a couple of things new things slight
I'll say improvements but um one of the
new updates that we've added is for the
order flow ratios okay um let me just
pull up the indicator settings here okay
so you know in the past you know every
bar has a ratio okay and in the past
they would be colored blue if it was
bullish red if it was bearish you know
above the bar if it was bearish below
the bar if it was bullish and if it was
just normal order flow it' be colored
black but we added a new feature in
here called uh the text color for the
regular ratios okay so you have a ratio
bounds High a ratio bounds low okay 30
and
69 and so if it's above 30 or below 69
it's either going to be blue or red okay
but if it's not if it's just your normal
order flow it's not going to draw the
the ratio under
or above okay so that was one of the
things a lot of people have been asking
for that over the years but I always
like to have them on there just to get
an idea you know because again you know
even though these numbers are what I use
30 and 69 it wasn't like set in stone
okay because if a a ratio came out at
29.8 which is below
30 is that to say that it's not a
legitimate ratio you know that's a Jud
call I'd like to make okay the same
thing with uh you know 0.69 if it came
in at at 7 um does that mean it's not
important well again that's a judgment
call you can make now one of the other
big updates that we've made which is
something that uh I like to use I like
to use it a lot is under the global
settings you see swing period okay and
now with majority of all the tools the
existing tools and the new tools you
have a
choice to enable the swing filter okay
so for example okay let's talk about
let's go to the ratios really quick okay
if I were to enable this swing filter
okay hit apply it's going
to look
for ratios or it's not going look for
it's going to only highlight the ratios
that appear at a swing high or a swing
low over a five period okay that's what
that is Swing period of five so for
example right let me get
the crosshairs up here this is a bearish
ratio right here at this swing High you
don't see any other ratios coming in
here right because these
are not at swing highs or swing lows it
would have to be a ratio
that meets the requirements that's
coming in at a swing high or swing low
right of the period that I chose okay so
you know you're not going to see
sometimes a lot of ratios at all if
you're using a swing filter okay because
it's only going to be looking at swing
highs swing lows swing highs swing lows
okay and it's got to meet the
requirement you know for a bearish ratio
or a bullish ratio okay and you see
today in the e-
minis what was that that was one okay so
far this is most of the day it's
just when you start filtering things out
occurring at swing highs or swing lows
obviously it's not going to occur as
often as opposed
to um not using a swing filter and
people are going to say well why why do
I got to use it well you don't have to
right that's why we give you the choice
um to use it or not but something like
the orderful ratios I I wouldn't me
personally I just use it separately all
right so let's uh now that we got that
those two little things out of the way
let's take a look at the new tools not
going to talk about the existing tools
okay because you know I've talked about
those for years right everyone's here
because you're interested in in the new
tools okay
so what I'm going to do is just just
going to make this a little bit cleaner
here I'll turn off the Delta
Divergence I'll turn off the point of
well I can turn off the ratios I'll turn
off the point of controls again this is
just a brand new chart that I literally
just opened you saw here so I'm just
using the defaults but it's a little bit
easier if you're looking at a plain
footprint chart um you know over the
next few weeks I'm going to be doing
more videos more trainings um you know
showing you how to use these different
tools but really what I want you know
what everyone's interested in um from
the feedback that I got is explain the
new tools okay so there's accumulation
distribution okay
and accumulation and
distribution
right you've all heard those terms
okay now there's three settings one you
got to enable it two obviously is the
swing filter three is sort of this other
one that I like to use is passive
traders in control because if you're
just looking at
accumulation
distribution um sometimes you know
you're going to see a lot more than
really meets the eye and this is
important in some markets you see a lot
of them okay now this is just way to
read the order flow okay now in e- minis
you know a market that trades heavy
volume it I don't say it's deceiving but
it looks like there's a lot right almost
every bar has one um let me just close
this down you know if you're if you're
looking at this today okay you're like
oh geez you know what am I supposed to
do with this it's like here these blue
blue blue blue this is accumulation a
lot of accumulation well that's why I've
added this uh tool here this other
setting called passive
Traders being in control okay because
it's one thing to just to have you know
good volume right but really when you're
looking at accumulation or distribution
it's going to be the passive traders
that are showing their hands okay so you
could see here now right okay yeah you
had one here some selling come in but
you see it's blue blue blue blue blue
blue you know it's mostly blue we're
going higher this day you know even on
the little pullbacks right by the dip
well what's going to give you the
motivation to buy the dip well if you
know that there's accumulation taking
place you know you'd be interested in
doing that you know these snps um it's
hard to find distribution because we
just seem to be Defying Gravity um you
know in the
market this looks like it's being
distribution obviously got that heavy
volume
1778 but you know just wasn't uh just
this is probably some big seller I was
looking at this this morning um you know
Market was going down and someone just
sort of puked out a position here at 18
and the market ran up from there but you
can see right on a uptrending market you
tend to have a lot of those blue zones
um sort of another thing that you could
even do take it a step
further
is again now if you add a swing filter
again it's a global setting five so if I
use
the swing filter with um accumulation
distribution with you know a Delta
breakout exhaustion prints by Ena all
those it's going to be linked to this
one you can't you know you're not I
don't you know people say why why is it
all linked together why is it a global
setting and not an individual setting
because there are a couple of the um
indicators that do have individual
settings because it's not you know
you're not trying to curve fit it and
you know say well accumulation
distribution with a swing filter of
eight and then you know exhaustion print
with a swing filter of three and you
know um a Delta breakout with a swing
filter of 10 you know no right I I think
that's the wrong way to approach it
that's why we've done it that way if you
were to you know enable That Swing
filter on accumulation distribution
again swing filter will filter out
everything else that's not coming in at
a swing
high or a swing low okay so if you see
accumulation and distribution you know
now you see like practically none
um
you know here's a distribution level
from way earlier but let's just look
here during the day you know there's a
accumulation some distribution taking
place
there little accumulation here before
that pop up um here this Blue Area some
accumulation coming
in okay so you know when you add the
swing filter obviously you're going to
get
less
okay so that is the accumulation
distribution now the next one is align
point of
controls
and align point of controls is simple
right I I wrote about this years ago in
um my point control course you know it's
a sign of pick of it this way right
point of control is what it's the price
level in the bar with the most volume
and if it's
consistently the same price over several
bars especially if you're looking at a
minute base chart well what's that
telling you you know Traders are happy
to transact at these prices right you're
going to be looking them as support
areas support that's why it's green
right red would be resistance right
here's you even got support here support
here
um this one you know since it's a point
of control
one
basically we're looking for Align point
of controls this one does not have the
um swing filter on there I didn't want
to put it on there because I to me this
is more of a visual thing as I want to
see how the market is reacting as it
comes out of that area
now again depending on the market that
you're using or trading rather um you
know for
example let's take a look at uh I think
bonds where we were marcher so should be
in the June Bonds on a
uh you bonds I like to use a range based
chart okay now if you're using a range
based chart right I'll say some of these
tools perform better but look at this
right this is a range-based chart on
bonds okay 9 o' you know there's one
there a little bit you know after n
after the market moved you're seeing
strong um signal with the Align point of
control
here you know this one you know 4 in the
morning didn't go anywhere that was 5 in
the afternoon you see here during the
day yesterday 7:50 in the morning right
so the market uh makes a nice move
higher honestly I didn't even look at uh
an eight range chart or a 10 range but
use an eight range chart here in the S&P
I'm kind of curious now
um you know see how it looks you know
sometimes you know when you're looking
at a minute based chart versus a range
based chart you get not different
signals but the way the bars are formed
are much different so you can see here
right on the cash close before we
dropped obviously there bullish there
was a bearish one here nice bullish one
here it's a bearish one it didn't just
really go anywhere this one pulled back
a little bit before going up to that
area sold off a little bit you know so
it's kind of mixed you know you did
catch some nice moves here and there
there's a nice move
down although that's right at nine
o'clock but right before 9ine nice move
up
so that's the aligned point of controls
okay and again it doesn't matter whether
you're using a one minute chart or a
eight range chart or 10 range
chart find the tools that help you
understand what you're looking at in the
order flow okay um you know some people
and notice the ones that are most
successful with orderflow right they
they pick out a few pieces of some of
the tools right and
they they don't add everything that's
not the whole point right is oh you got
all these tools I mean just enable
everything and go from there like oh I'm
going to enable accumulation
distribution align Point control Delta
breakouts Divergence Tails everything go
from there no that that that's not the
point of it really the point is to um
find the ones that help you understand
what you're looking at in the order flow
okay that's that's really the whole
point of having these different tools
right you know I wrote that book or that
course the orderflow trade encyclopedia
where I listed
like 128 130 I forgot what it was 128
trade setups everyone's like oh my gosh
there's so much to memorize no there's
not you you memor you you use the ones
that help you understand what you're
looking at in the order flow all right
so let me just go back really quick to
uh just a simple minute based chart
here and then uh we'll take a look at
the next
one okay guys I see a lot of questions
coming in I'm going to hold the
questions until um the
end okay so buying and selling tail is a
existing one Delta breakouts a new one
okay and it analyzes Delta okay now
people going to say say well this is
Delta breakout the same as Delta surge
or
Delta um scalper this or Delta that no
it's not it's its own unique
um setup here so hang on a second I
think I still got the Align PC's on I
just turned that off
now what it does is it analyzes the
Delta it's looking for growth in the
Delta either Positive Growth or negative
growth okay and where's the thing here
200 okay so you could set it at you know
whatever value you like um I find
200 is a good starting point okay and so
you're going to see you know like here's
a bearish one here's a bullish one um
it's a bearish one bullish one okay
bearish one bullish one but again
depending on the market that you're
looking at 200 might be
kind of weak or if I was looking at say
you
know grains or even currencies 200 might
be too strong
okay so all you got to do is you go in
there again you got to sort of narrow it
down because again you know we all look
at different types of charts so people
going to say oh can you can you make a a
sheet and just say you know for every
Market what it's going to be well then
you got okay well what kind of chart you
looking at so again it it's it's a
personal Journey right I mean if you
wanted to make it you know 500 you can
right say you're trading a three minute
chart 5 minute chart make it a thousand
um you know it's up to you to make it
whatever you want but 200 is a good good
starting point so you see here right
it's a little bit stronger so you got to
delt the breakout here another one
here all right here's a little bearish
one you know another bullish
one right the bearish
one
now just really quick again it might be
a little hard to see I don't want the
the issue was um coming up with the
right color scheme for everybody and
then I know people go say I can't see it
on your screen in this
presentation
um you know I have to make it for you to
see it I'd have to make it like 80 here
but what you can do okay
another thing you can do is you could
add a filter right the swing back uh
swing the swing filter right again it's
linked to the global
setting okay so I've enabled it right
I'm still using in this case
500 okay so now right it's looking for
Delta breakouts you know at a at a swing
High here this one started to then went
sideways uh um you know there was one
there today you didn't get a whole lot
but again that's at 500 so it's kind of
strict um if I were to step it down to
this default which I think is just 200
let's take a look
here okay again and I'm just choosing
today's action in The e- Minis here I'm
not trying to like go back and find the
perfect one and show you I'm just
showing you how it looks you know some
days are going to be better um than
others okay here right that's your
bearish one this your bearish one
bearish one you know we're trending
higher today bearish so trending higher
it's like every time someone try to take
profits they take it and then the market
just goes
up that's nine so basically since eight
there was no bullish ones with the swing
filter I mean if I were to go back to um
you know
yesterday
who
knows yeah yesterday not really showing
much buys with the swing filter on but
anyway that is the uh Delta breakout
okay so now let's uh let's just move on
to the next one um one of the other
changes we made I didn't put it down as
as any new thing or anything but the
Delta Divergence now this is enabled
when you log in but it's enabled to only
show at the high or the low of the
day
um what we've done is we've added the
swing filter okay
and why is that important
well you know one of my favorite trades
is bullish or bearish ratio with
Divergence okay
but it doesn't you know Divergence in
the true sense is going to be at the
high or the low of the day but there's
going to be times where you know
Divergence at a swing High here does
that mean it's not important well you
know it can be important you can see how
this you know Market hit the high came
off came back up when sideways came back
up to the high and then sold off right
this is yesterday let me just go back to
today stuff
um you know you see this one level from
earlier Market came right you know this
Divergence here you see Divergence
here um another Divergence
here Divergence Divergence Divergence
that bullish Divergence Now the default
colors are gold I I didn't change you
know blue or anything like that blue for
buys or red for sells if you wanted to
you could do that in there I just I'm so
used to looking at it as gold color
um that I kept it that but you can see
here CU you know I often talk about
recognizing a trend day
early is on the back of a lot of failed
divergences right a market making new
highs or new lows right sort of
consistently but let me just go
back um where am I going here
yesterday I don't know if yesterday was
a good example but that might the
earlier in the
week but imagine right if you're looking
at divergences that are failing in One
Direction or
another both I don't have a really good
Trend day per se in this
market let
try I don't know if bonds had them let's
take a look
here you know Bonds were moving you know
snp's
moves okay so let just turn it on
here because basically when you see you
know sort of a lot of fail divergences
in a short period of time it's usually
indicative of some sort of profit taken
you don't really see much here one here
one here one here we haven't got back up
there yet but even here right you can
see how you know it's finding a lot of
decent turning points imagine you short
this okay you failed and you short this
one you got a nice move along this one
nice move
up okay
so um you know with failed divergences
right if this blow were to break here
I'd probably be looking for this Market
to go um
lower you know just like here failed
Divergence failed Divergence failed
Divergence came down here you broke it
you Dro a sell stop in here okay um but
that that's one I don't really consider
that a new upgrade grade but there was
just something that I had been wanting
to have done for a while um but we we
put it in on this version now let's just
sort of get back uh to the next
one and it's I'm just going in
alphabetical order here so I'll turn
that off Delta tale is a new
one again it's Delta taale for those of
you that are not familiar
with my Delta trading course is
basically you have a bar right a green
up candle that has negative Delta on the
bottom price level and positive Delta
all the way up
so sometimes it's hard to see on a on a
footprint chart like this if you were to
make your chart a Delta footprint it
could be easier to see so let me just
but the beauty is you don't need to be
looking at a Delta footprint here but to
make it easier to explanation for those
of you that aren't familiar with
it I'll just pull it up here here really
quick so the Delta footprint right it
looks at Delta on the bid in the offer
right so you can see here so I can see
this is positive Delta this is negative
Delta so it tells me this is a Delta
tail it's coming in at the top it's a
red candle so what's happened is
aggressive
buying is being absorbed it's it's a
sign of near-term absorption
okay and you know you can see here you
know
here now
here that didn't work
um you know right here and here one
right after the other a couple more here
one two three four
five excuse
me you see the market coming
down now with this
also say you're looking at you say oh
my that's just too many signals am
I supposed to deal with that you could
filter it out with the swing
filter okay so you just enable swing
filter give it a second
now just really quick right bonds for
range
chart kind of curious oh what I'll do is
uh turn off this other
stuff
oh I had a line you see is on here turn
that off Delta break uh Delta tail here
we go on this one I won't
use I won't use the swing
filter you see here boom boom boom boom
boom
boom all right up up down down
up again you
know this one's with the swing filter on
I don't know if there's
any there was n the S&P is weird day
well that was yesterday let's go back to
today you know uh this one these little
signs here this is from the Stacked
imbalance
again this would be a tail this would be
a tail but we're using the swing filter
so it's not filtering any out at a swing
high or a swing
low so again you know if you're using a
swing filter depending on the market you
may see some things you may not see
anything okay so see on the
snps there's none
but in bonds without the swing filter
you're seeing some nice trades if I were
to turn off this swing filter
I can see a bullish one here depends you
got to find out you know which ones you
want to use with a swing filter or not
Delta
tail is probably one yeah if
you're you probably don't want to use a
swing filter right if you're trading at
night where it's a lot slower and
volume's a lot
lesser yeah then you'll probably want to
use the swing filter but if you're
during the normal trading days the US
hours right you want to be able to take
advantage of these moves here here here
right you know this one here right you
see these bullish moves here
here all right uh let's move on here so
I'll turn
this chart back to a footprint normal
bid ask
footprint get out of the Delta mode
and all right so that was uh what was
that Delta
tail yeah exhaustion prce existing one
but we've added the swing filter now
imbalance reload okay there's no swing
filter on
this
and what it is
is you know when you look at imbalances
right Traders look at imbalances they
they look at it on a bar by bar basis
all right because we're always looking
for you know the the the Stacked selling
imbalance right or a stacked buying
imbalance right or we're looking at
where it comes in on a
bar but there's times like here right
you got one bar buying and balance the
next bar buying and balance at the same
level well you sort of has
sustained trading coming in right
because imagine what happens right this
bar goes and you got the aggressive
buying they move it higher Market pulls
back aggressive buyers coming in at that
same
price okay this was a a bearish one
here you know again normally we look at
imbalances we're just looking for
stacked imbalances or big imbalances in
the bar um but we're not looking at sort
of the sustained buying or selling now
with this one you got to be careful okay
because especially like if you're
looking at it in you
know you know here 6:30 in the morning
you know 28 this is 5 28 and 70 right 20
and 94 you know 2241 ideally you want
the volume to be you know legitimate you
know some strong volume coming in okay
you don't want to just pick light
volumes you know
3671 you want something pretty strong
ideally you know 300
321 right here is 454 and then 23 you
know would I like it you know I prefer
it this way because I know I got strong
selling that's being sustained strong
aggressive selling that's being
sustained that is um you know over
time this again looking at
today you know 263 491 Even This Bar had
2011 right sustained buying sustained
aggressive buying here there's some
selling
right right
here um next one just move move along
here so I'm trying to go quickly because
I don't want to keep everyone on on
Friday afternoon um okay so that's
imbalance
reload imbalance reversal is existing
one inverse volume imbalance Market
sweep detector Market weakness detector
and we've added swing filters to all of
these okay I particularly like
one of my ones I like to use the swing
filter on is Market
weakness okay so you're looking because
again you know why would you want to use
swing filter on Market weakness is
because you know imine Market's coming
into a high or to a
low and buying or selling is is
weakening okay I don't know if there was
any
today but you know here right I'm just
scrunching this chart
make it a little bit easier to
read you know here was a bullish one
here right right
here and again you could adjust what you
look back period you know sort of the
Swing period that you want there's one
here not a strong not the strongest
pullback you know there was one here
doesn't you know this was on the reopen
the other day but you can see that
imagine if you're buying at 87 right
gets all the way up into the 90s
there okay so there's a nice one here
this was the other day and again you
know you don't have to use the swing
filter
but it's there for you now okay and I do
think you have to put what's happening
in the market in context right and that
gives you the ability to do that all
right open point of control now this has
its own swing period we call it look
back bars okay set to five which is what
the global one is setting again you
could set it higher if you want
10 let's just turn it on
here
sort of go back to where we are
today okay so you're going to see the
point of controls are either going to be
this kind of purplish color or this dark
blue color them that way because we want
you to confuse them with the prominent
oppent controls or anything else and
really what's happening is again point
of control is what it's the price level
in the bar with the most volume and you
know you know if you studied technical
analysis everything you've read up till
now tells you well when a market has
healthy you know if a move has healthy
volume behind it then it's a legitimate
move but the second that if volume take
it a step further if volume is going
higher and price is going
higher not just price going higher but
volume going higher
that is also a sign of a strong move so
if I see these areas where it's a blue
blue blue I know that volume is
migrating higher not just price because
again you know if you're just looking at
Price going higher on light volume
probably the move isn't going to be that
strong okay here here here obviously
this one comes in because you know
someone just puked out 1,700 contracts
you see on this move up boom boom boom
boom boom boom
right that's
9:00 but you can just see how you know
volume generally goes higher you got a
healthy move taking place I even looked
on the bonds but I'm kind of
curious how it looks
here
okay
open
PC I'll just leave it at five what was
that other thing I had on in here Delta
Tales turn that
off there's the bonds boom boom boom
boom boom
boom you
know catch this move what is that
12 it's up to up to the
figure it's a nice move catch you know
even on the way down here this morning
right again you know is a minute based
chart in the e- minis wise TR I show
that because a lot of Traders use it you
know I have markets that I like to
trade and a lot of these tools work
nicely with that so if you're trading
Bonds on a four range chart take a look
at open point of
controls now the next one whoops this is
bonds um let's go back to e- minis is
the orderflow gaps
this is a
new thing here so let's find it
here turn off open Point
controls turn on gaps now with this
one or full gaps if you're not using the
swing
filter you might see a little too many
for your own for your taste which is
again you know for some people you know
they're probably cool with that maybe I
don't know and default is fixed you can
actually draw it out until tested if you
like um if it's fixed it'll just show
the gap between the two bars here and
here here I I made it this darker color
just for people to see
um on this presentation but it's a it's
a lighter blue and a lighter pink
now what I said is you can
use the swing filter on this and it
becomes much more
effective in my opinion as opposed to
just every time there's a gap
there and where is it here swing filter
again default setting up here is five
it's under the global
settings give a second here
it's got to do quite a bit of
calculations so you can see here
bullish all right a couple bearish here
as we're getting up to these highs it's
a bearish one bullish one that just went
sideways bearish here bullish
here and then that's going into the cash
close um you know even if you go back a
little
earlier bullish one here obviously on
the back of this bearish one you got the
bullish here where you going to place
your stop obviously it's going to be
below the first bar where the Gap
appears just as here if you're short
here your stop would be up here buy this
one your stop would be below
here yeah that's today if you go
back yesterday yeah I'm not going to say
yeah you could have take advantage of
that but uh there was there was one
there
um yeah there going to be times like
this where the just don't work out
okay
so again you can see these bullish one
here just one sideways you know that is
I'm kind of curious here on the uh bonds
since I like to flip through these
markets real quick take a look at bonds
with
it gaps use the
swing I don't even know if I need the
swing filter but turn off open Point
controls try it with the swing filter I
don't know I don't know how it looks
here is bullish one here was a bearish
one let's go back to today here it's a
bearish one here there's a bearish one
here there's a bearish one here bullish
one here bearish here so you got going
back to midnight bearish bullish
bearish bullish bearish beish
bearish okay that's so that's the
orderflow gaps that's a new one now
let's take a look
at I think the next one is uh okay so
disable this sequencing right we added
to look back ratios already went over
with price action
Divergence okay now this
one this was sort of a a last minute one
um that we added literally
just earlier this week um it just sort
of snuck it in there but
uh you know when you have a green candle
right an up candle right you generally
have positive Delta right if you've got
a red candle you generally have negative
Delta okay but there's times where the
market is going up green candle green
candle green candle and you got negative
Delta that's what this looks for okay
why is it going up on negative Delta is
because you got strong passive buyers
bidding up the market that are absorbing
whatever aggressive selling is taking
place um okay let's write on the cache
open but you see here right you got the
green candle negative Delta so I just
drawing that green
here you've got red
candle positive Delta so there's Supply
up in here okay yeah you you here you're
going sideways right between here and
here you get long here okay doesn't work
out just go sideways on you and you get
the short signal right before the market
dropped got a Divergence here but didn't
go anywhere right next bar just doesn't
even go any higher there's a bullish one
here sort of came back to that
area not that in
there these are just stacked buying and
selling IM balances I should have turned
that off but uh you can see right here
new high swing High 97 red candle why
because you got absorption taking place
up there this one
failed this one failed this one
worked but that's at 8 at night with
kind of thin volumes let's go back to
sort of the day session
today okay Cash open ran up right up
here you got a Divergence right negative
sorry positive Delta on this red candle
44 right here you got a
Divergence okay so bearish
bullish it's a bearish one that
failed bearish one bullish
one
couple of B three bullish ones here here
here this one had a nice little move
this one not so much this one okay
another bullish one here another bearish
one here at the cash close now again I I
highly
recommend use the swing filter if you
don't use the swing filter you're going
to see a lot honestly
um so just disable that kind of curious
on uh on
bonds let's look at the bond market here
real quick
with it where is it
here turn off the
gaps well for this one on since this
moves differently I'll just leave
the so you can see right if if you have
it turned off right you see a lot one
two
three you see bearish ones
here but on the minis you're going to
see a lot more right almost you know it
happens with regular with
regularity see one two three you know
here here it's interesting because you
can sort of see areas where the market
is kind of being supported here here
here here here you do get the odd red
one in
there but if you're looking at it on a
bar by bar basis it it's pointless right
because it's hard to really there's no
context to it that's why I recommend
using the swing
filter okay so let moving
on uh what was that that was price
action
Divergence so
slingshot is an existing one um we've
added the swing filter to that but let's
talk about this one PC wave okay that's
a that's a PC setup three
bars you know you start with bar one
which is like uh the neutral bar and bar
two has a lower point of control bar
three has the higher point of
control um let's just find one where
there's basically at the sort of same
levels so you can see here right so
first bar neutral it's green candle then
red candle higher point of control
control Market started going up Trad
some volume then starts coming down and
as it comes down it's got a lower point
of control so point of control then Red
Bar Red Bar higher and lower point of
control just says Red Bar Green Bar
lower point of
control second green bar higher point of
control
okay here
here here and here but really and I know
a lot of Traders are are using this with
other tools um other forms of
analysis but I don't know if they've
thought about uh looking at
it with a swing
filter and I know guys that are using
this like when when Market comes up to a
level and they see a POC wave take place
at that level you know it's like go time
but we can also trade it by
itself with the swing filter you you
know
here sorry that's uh early morning going
the wrong direction so that's a bearish
one there okay another bearish one kind
of went sideways nothing bullish today
there a bearish
one
bearish bullish just sort of went
sideways before it went
up bearish again you know today was
Friday after a long freaking week
but
uh how does it look on the bonds let's
take a look here turn off this
Divergence I'll just leave
the filter off okay so you see bullish
one here bearish
bullish bullish bearish bearish bearish
bullish bearish bullish bearish and
that's with the swing filter off so you
can see everything if you have the swing
filter off you'll see them all if you're
using the swing filter
on you know you'd see this one probably
this one this one this one this
one so it's up to you if you want to use
the swing
filter yeah I like to use the swing
filter I I like to take trades when
we're coming up into a swing high or
swing low because to me that's a sign of
you know an area that you can reverse
right because that means you know if
you're trading a
reversal you want to have a move to
reverse period right if the move isn't
going you know how you going to trade
reversal and you know from reversals
that's where you can get very nice moves
potentially you can reverse and go to
the the lows or reverse and go to the
highs so to me those those are the
um opportunity times you know opportuni
knocking um are you going to take
advantage of it all right so prent
opponent controls no change there it's
all the same these have their own look
back swing periods we call them look
back
bars resting
liquidity okay there's two types of
liquidity there's resting
liquidity and there is vertical
liquidity okay resting liquidity is
horizontal vertical is um think of
vertical as stacked let me turn off the
Stacked imbalance okay so where am I
here resting liquidity okay now again
this one has a volume threshold
depending on the market that you're
trading you may need to adjust it in the
time frame you're trading again 200 is
set for E Minis and what it's going to
do it's going to color the volume areas
in black and it's going to draw the the
text A Little Bit Stronger you see in
here
right 15 and it's going to be
bold
okay so you can see here right these are
areas of resting liquidity all
right bearish is going to be this Sor
this red color bullish is going to be
this green color okay and it's measuring
it
over
time okay now there's ways to trade it
right I like to look
for you know because again it's volume
basically is what it is I'm not going to
say it's some big fancy algorithm it's
volume spread out over bars
basically and you want to take advantage
of it as soon as possible again so
whether you're using a minute base chart
a range based
chart it's best you know used quickly
right any order flow is best used
quickly right and again you know when
you're looking at it ideally you want to
take it as soon as possible and that
like here people say well you know there
so you you said there's res in liquid
here I got long well yeah but there's
rest in liquid all on the way up you
came in late it's like people that
bought you know Bitcoin three years ago
at at 60,000 you know they're up0 2%
right now you know they had to wait a
long time so if you're buying it at a
high price instead of getting in
earlier you're missing out basically um
you can also use the swing
filter it's going to filter out a lot of
these trades actually if you use the
swing filter
filter and it's it's fixed I don't know
you could draw it out until tested if
you wanted to but we we have the default
set at
fixed but if I was looking at a
different Market okay so this is e minis
let's just give it a second to come up
here but you know if I'm looking excuse
me
if I'm you looking at
bonds right
200 because you know here you're trading
thousands at a price level okay so you
know maybe you know for sure 200 is
is too small a number
um you you'd have to adjust it based on
your Market I wouldn't use 200 here
um
gosh I
even 500 is probably too light as well
you probably need to use um a bit
stronger but let's take a look here so
here's no not bad here's bullish signal
a couple bullish signals so 500 again
that's just off the top of my head
there's 500 here here here here
right it's taking out that wrestling
liquidity
right blue means means getting long
right if there was any you there's these
oranges areas you can be looking to
short short short
short okay but let's go back here this
is
um you know with the swing
filter okay now with the swing filter
here we did it sort of opposite because
you can't
look to get long you're not going to see
the you're not going to see the volume
coming in generally I mean here was big
offer coming in at a swing low generally
as the market starts moving away from a
low and people are offering it
out when you're looking at liquidity you
know think of it how how to describe it
right if you imagine for a second close
your eyes and imagine you know a heat
map right with liquidity coming in okay
you know the those if you're looking at
heat map right you see the bars coming
in you know here right and you know I
some Traders will see liquidity coming
in here at 25 think I gota get short but
what happens when the market eats
through that
liquidity at 25 it's probably going
higher it's going to look for the next
area of liquidity just as this Market is
going higher takes out that liquidity
where's it going to go the next part the
next point of liquidity now this is
volume that actually traded okay so
we're measuring the liquidity that
actually traded and saying hey that's
important
here here here you don't need to wait
till the third one be getting long you
should be getting long after the second
one or sorry after the first one before
the second one even takes place just as
here Market's going down takes out
liquidity here and
here
no during data release but um you know
that's during the cash open during the
cash open generally you're going to see
liquidity pick up anyway because you see
a lot of orders come into the market but
hopefully you get the idea there um all
right so let's take a look at the next
one I'll get
to Vertical liquidity shortly but I'm
just going through these alphabetically
I don't want to skip any of the new ones
retail suck it doesn't mean retail
Traders suck it just it it's basic think
of it as retail Traders getting sucked
in to bad positions okay I'll show it to
you with swing filter disabled not
enabled
these the colors are this color scheme
is kind of new it's kind of like this
chartreuse
here and the sort of magenta but let's
take a look here okay let's go
back okay so like here this
morning okay bullish bearish
bearish
there's a bearish one from
earlier it's basically looking at the
order flow in the
bar and seeing that hey you know what
right the lower you know volume was
increasing on the way down right
basically trap Traders you
know
here all right now one thing I like with
this one
is again something like this because the
the volume decline is sort of this is
very similar to
it so you to make a a swing filter again
this a minute based chart you know
minute based charts things look
different on if I was going to show you
a range based chart it would look vastly
different I'll start here I don't know
if there's any signals today there's a
bearish one market just went
sideways yeah that was it on a range
based chart let Goose quickly on an
eight range
chart this is our trusty Bond chart
let's take a look add it to the bond
chart uh is that here I'm not going to
aable that disable the Stacked
balance
okay
here
here couple ones that didn't work out
here this this is the
uh resting liquidity I I didn't disable
that that's a nice move there this is a
beautiful move here
obviously let's take a look here the e-
minis that's right before the cash
close bearish one went
sideways bearish one
here you know some people love to use
range based charts because it takes out
the time element right it just based off
of price movements
okay
there's none in here okay here was one
here where's the interesting where the
market comes back up to
there there some bullish one there at
8:30 another bullish one right here day
couple days
ago um but anyway that is the retails
retail suck um this basically Traders
getting sucked into bad positions it's
another way to say trap Traders uh
stacked imbalance don't need to explain
we did add the swing filter on there so
if you're looking at stacked imbalances
at a swing high or swing low only same
with thin prints we've added the swing
filter value areas no change we there's
no swing filter to the value areas every
bar has a value area you're not just
going to look for bars that have a value
area to swing High I mean every bar has
one it's based on volume same with
engulfing value now vertical
liquidity
okay let's just enable this real quick
excuse
me okay just give it a second
here okay so again this one is volume
dependence right you see a lot of blue
sorry green strips up red strips down
okay think of it
as
stacked uh liquidity you know stacked
volume okay over certain amount
basically um again depending on the
market and the chart type this is an
eight range
chart it's volume dependent so you're
going to have to find
it
on find the the volume that you want to
use based on your chart type again not
everyone uses the same chart type okay
we all use sort of different chart types
okay so this is on a Time base chart
right you don't see as many still see
them
here okay
now if you could adjust it you know
maybe 200 is too light for you maybe
want a stronger
volume where is it
here you
know 200 is kind of light maybe you want
to make it
okay you just change it all right right
there now cluster size is how many
levels it is one level two levels three
three is you know quite
strong okay so you could see there was
one
here couple in here again towards the
cach open you're going to get a lot of
volume both directions so I'm not
surprised to see this bar has got
two um you know here's one's got a feel
there's another one got a a few another
one got a
few you know you see this Market is
going up it's there's a lot of liquidity
that's being removed from the
market these are coming in at subsequent
higher
levels okay so if
you um you
know one of the things you could adjust
okay so I said set it at volume at 400
okay you canjust how many levels so say
you want to set it
at uh vertical liquidity so 400 change
it to two so it's only got to be you
know two subsequent price levels 400 or
more but maybe I you know let keep it at
400 okay and hit up
obviously there should be more because
we lowered the threshold by one price
level down to
two Okay so you're seeing in here right
here there's a lot more right coming
in but what you can do then right if
you're going to go that
route
is what you can always do is add the
swing filter
filter okay what am I doing here apply
hit
okay okay so you're
looking I I got to double check this
swing filter on this
one you may have it uh programmed the
wrong way yeah nothing's coming up
anyway I'll have to with my program on
that make a note there swing filter
on
vertical uh
[Music]
liquidity he should have made it the
same way
as the resting liquidity one I think he
still got it programmed the other way
around backwards
but we'll get that sorted out don't
worry all right so so let's move on
to volume
decline all right volume decline simple
one sequential decline you've all heard
of that
probably you know it's decreasing volume
on the way up of a red candle or
decreasing volume on the way down of a
green candle although in the old days
you know they used to say on both ends
of the candle they didn't they didn't
care um but I sort of refined it to
being on a red down candle you're
looking at these three price levels on a
green up candle you're looking at these
bottom three price levels and often
times you do have a lot of bars
exhibiting that okay which can frustrate
you okay but again that is
something because if you're looking at
volume drying up or getting weaker on a
move you want a move to happen right
that is why you add the swing
filter now we have the draw mode as
fixed you could actually keep it fixed
or you can draw it out until tested
right when the market comes back to that
area yeah an area
that Traders were you know sort of
getting away from what is going on
no here we go
here here
here here right if if these were fixed
sometimes it's a little easier to
see these are fixed but if these were
until tested
rather
may be a lot clear let's make this a
little bit darker for you guys to
see and again you know whether you're
looking at bonds
or snps let's take a look here at this
one
where are we here volume
decline uh what was that other one I got
on there take you off here and I'm going
to take off the rest of
liquidity you see here right bullish
bullish bullish bearish bullish bullish
bullish bullish bearish bearish bearish
bullish all
right bearish bullish bearish bearish
bearish bearish
bullish this is it with the zones drawn
out so you can see here here here right
here right and then obviously the cash
close um let's take a look here some I
think that's
the that's the last one made it
through volume
decline disable you volume
imbalance we set it so that you could
enable the swing filter
okay before we didn't have the swing
filter on here for multiple imbalances I
like to see multiple imbalances at
swings swing highs or swing
lows and so you just enable the swing
filter enable multiple imbalances um
zero print unfinished business that's
all the same there's change to the
latter contents summary contents is all
the same volume profile is all the same
so let's see if there was any
here today multiple imbalance is at
swing highs or swing lows there's
multiple selling IM balances here and
here buying and selling there that was
today so that 9 o'clock time some goofy
happened
uh a bearish one
there bearish there again that's a
minute based chart if you're on a range
based
chart just take a look here and the
thing to note with that one the volume
imbalance it's linked to the global
setting for the imbalances of depend on
what you're using uh the default is set
at uh let take a look here for 4 to1
400%
okay all right so this is what it looks
like on a trending Market profit taking
profit taking profit
taking it's a bullish one there bullish
one
here there's a bullish one here a
bearish one up
here
bearish one that didn't
work that's a nice bearish one right
there um but anyway uh let's take a look
at some of this other stuff I think that
should about Do It
um zero print no change unfinished
business summary contents all the same
volume profile yeah that's all
um you know just
really quick
here where am I
here if I'm going to go take a look at
some questions you know if if you want
to know more about it just go to this
page of
s.com
of7 the number
seven right and you can scroll down here
right it talks about all the
new uh here you get down in here
accumulation distribution open point of
controls align gaps reloads volume
declines PC wave liquidities Delta
breakout retail
sucks retail sucks the retail suck I
should really put the in front there um
price action Divergence Etc then you
know the existing ones that you still
get
there um for those of you that don't
have it you can get it down here we've
actually added a new bonus the workshop
that we did in October as well still 749
I've getting a lot of pressure from my
people to raise the price so if I keep
it at 749 for a week or so then it will
probably increase to
uh I don't know 849 I think is what
they're talking about but anyway I'm
going burn through some questions here